[Music]
with the roe v wade stuff going on i
understand that it'd be pretty pointless
for a bunch of guys in a room to be
talking about what we think of it oh
speak for yourself i got so many
opinions as a man
i think it might be more valuable to
share any personal stories that we might
have with abortion itself in the past
well i'll start
can't wait
well as a group of dudes man we've never
had abortion so what do you mean uh
here's here's something that might be
kind of interesting i've got 20 friends
that did it
20 different friends they were the
aborted
no uh
so like i growing up seventh-day
adventist you're just kind of programmed
already to be against abortion no matter
what you even want to hear i didn't even
know it was a thing until like way later
like like high school or something right
cause like they don't even mention it
all we knew was to shame anybody that we
ever heard of that ever had it and then
uh right yeah that helps them scarlet
letter uh whole thing yeah so in high
school like i was already still super
against it we don't even talk about it
unless that's what you have to say
until
uh my girlfriend time got pregnant so
your girlfriend yeah oh [ __ ] so she
cheated on you and got pregnant no
immaculate conception
she was like the mother mary yeah well
she yeah it was when i was 16 and then
no 17. i was 17 in high school and she
goes
um
i'm pregnant
and i swear to god
my opinion switched that night wow and i
think that's a really important thing is
that everybody who says they take a
stance on a certain thing kind of has to
be faced with the issue itself
definitely i had never been more
pro-abortion than that exact moment that
she told me that sure and i totally went
against all my [ __ ] and went i'm not
ready for this kid i'm a [ __ ] 17 year
old idiot like so i don't i don't know
much about it but when i've whenever i
heard the concept of it
i've always felt like yeah it's the
probably the girl's choice
um but i don't know what are the main
arguing points besides anything that's
based in religion like why are moral
moral things well the main arguing
argument point would be
when is it considered living oh so at
what so it's like
so it's like that's what everybody's
arguing about yeah because i think most
christians would uh agree that the the
point of conscious uh contraception or
whatever like conception
yeah the point of
that's already i see it's already
fertilized egg is fully grown but then
but then some people will argue like no
not really until
maybe like i don't know two weeks in i
don't know third trimester yeah there's
so many there's different yeah depending
on who you talk to right or depending on
what state you're in yeah definitely but
the reverse is way does it make it like
like what do you call it like a like
abortion to league or anything like that
it just makes it yeah now it's the
states mandate like the states choose
versus the federal government you bet
the [ __ ] news doesn't say it like
that because holy [ __ ] no they don't
want to say it like that i think that's
why like i get i don't get the facts i
don't think like from the news so i
don't really abortion isn't illegal i
don't quite understand and then like the
way people are arguing i'm pretty sure
that's not the point of what you're
arguing you know they're just making it
so like the states can choose so then
now people are afraid that the states
that are in the bible belt that are
traditionally against um abortion and
stuff they might be like okay well we
have the freedom to do it then we're
just gonna ban it completely and that
makes it so that you know like people
are gonna go out and get illegal
abortions or they have to go out of
state or whatever yeah that's basically
the gist of all this stuff yeah that
kind of just goes to show right so that
those people they already disagreed with
this because it was like it was like law
in all of 50 states so they're going
well if it was up to our government we
wouldn't allow it in our state so even
though i personally agree with abortion
like that doesn't matter because it's up
to them in their state to have domain
over where they're at and what they
believe so
it's just one of those things where i
you know for me personally i'm like yo
anytime that like the scenario that
exists where if you want to enforce the
law you got to point a gun at a pregnant
lady's head for me i'm out i don't want
to have anything to [ __ ] do with that
right yeah but some people are like hey
man that's the law in my area and i'm
like well you go [ __ ] be there then
that's the thing that's interesting is
um
whenever i see anybody like and this is
a good example roe v wade because people
come out of the woodwork with their
super strong unwavering stalwart
opinions and like no nothing will change
my mind but then it i think the first
time i ever
shook on my beliefs was was this is that
when it was up to you yeah and when it
was me that's faced with it it's like
yeah it's easy to like stand on the side
and then be like no i will never do that
[ __ ] and then literally in the day i was
like i would do that [ __ ] honestly i
would because a lot of the rationale the
people that stand outside and pick it
they always go well don't don't abort it
won't you just adopt it like put it into
adoption right like that's like the best
solution and that's not to say that i
think that everybody who has a strong
you know opinion needs to have a
personal connection with dealing with
themselves i just think that's where you
really got to check yourself on your own
beliefs on whether or not they're that
like
all the way one color yeah uh so it's so
much greater also i think even a
practical viewpoint on it so yeah my
closest
i guess like association with abortion
was um
my mom got an abortion so i was the
first kid
and my mom and my dad had a really rocky
relationship and i was supposed to have
a little brother and i even remember uh
like being um maybe like three or four
being really excited to have a little
brother and we got like a sonogram
put on top of our tv but that's
something my mom would tell me and
there's like all these child pictures of
me standing next to my mom and my mom's
a maternity clothes
like she's about to have
have another kid
but the relationship between me and my
uh my mom and my dad was really bad
and then so i think they decided and i
think my dad didn't want it i think my
mom was down to keep because i think
most moms are more attached but my dad
didn't uh didn't want it so she was like
all right and then if you don't want
this then we're not gonna try again
you're just gonna be stuck with one kid
or whatever they ended up going through
with it didn't have it and i think they
changed her mind later on i don't know
if my mom was older or whatever but she
did get pregnant a third time but then
end up having a miscarriage but also
seeing how rocky their relationship is
and when like a kid
isn't conceived like the way that me and
geo planned it right and it's conceived
out of love and a goal
like we were buying her [ __ ] those
hipster ass smoothies every day so that
taika could have the best nutrients
right i [ __ ] smell secondhand smoke
i'm like get the [ __ ] out of here right
i'm like i'm like that type of care
versus like imagine like someone like my
mom or my dad in a rocky relationship
like well [ __ ] it i don't give a [ __ ]
the cigarette smoke here because then
your care is just different right so
even what that would because that's what
inspired my thought was when you're
saying like well just give it up for
adoption what about the eight
nine months leading up to that point
yeah yeah like what kind of
trash environment or maybe even fetal
alcohol syndrome like whatever crazy
[ __ ] that could go on because if you're
not in the right mindset of this is my
goal you're definitely not going to
prioritize anything that's going on here
yeah right well didn't geo have some
kind of [ __ ] honey grass shot or
something that scientists linked to kids
talking about their butts a lot
yeah
yeah honey glass shot
donkey doo doo so if you only you didn't
do that everything else was good yeah it
was great good job man i gotta seriously
consider should we keep this one i mean
he's gonna be [ __ ] talking about
butts every day
butts and poop that's all he talks about
in the sonogram it was just packed it
like muggles
and i think that's uh like with what
ryan's talking about too you know uh
until you actually like faced with it to
understand like you know even if you are
like okay suddenly i'm i'm pro-abortion
and it's like you know
like i i flipped the script on like what
i've grown up to believe or what i've
been taught or anything like that it's
at the end of the day even as dudes it
still like
isn't really our choice in that moment
you know what i'm saying like even to be
pro-boyfriend is still look at that that
woman and be like what do you want to do
and how can we support that because even
if like y'all honestly i'm not ready to
have a kid they're like i want to have
the kid it's kind of like well so what
are you going to do just bounce what do
you you know what i'm saying yeah
because at the same time i also had a
friend
they didn't plan it they had a kid and
in the minute uh they had a kid she
didn't even know if that dude was gonna
be
like the uh
like the caretaker and follow along with
the journey but then her mom had turned
on and the same exact way that like me
and gio had with tyka she just assumed
it on her own yeah so on the flip side
there are other people that are like you
know what um this is what happened so
i'm going to own it yeah i'ma rise to
occasion and just take care of it 100
percent and the way that her care was
throughout like all the trimesters was
insane too i think that some people
though are are very nice people and they
think that everyone's gonna love babies
as much as they love their babies yeah
like dude i was talking to this cat last
night at the at the hotel i'm staying at
and he was telling me about how he's
with this chick and they have like a
three-year-old kid and he's like yeah
i'm not even sure if i'm gonna stay with
her the kid's pretty cool but like i
don't know like like it's he's like it's
really [ __ ] annoying having a
three-year-old and he's like i just
wanna like sort of banger yeah i just
want to balance it will you tell me how
about how he wants to bounce
and like but yeah i don't think that
somebody who's like yeah babies should
be loved and cherished i don't think
that that's everybody obviously
and then like we talk about like foster
care stuff right like once a baby's born
and they're like i don't want anymore
they put in the foster system and then
that becomes a whole nother [ __ ]
complete gray area and so much trauma
all this craziness that comes out of
that whole like system like there's so
many different variables that people
don't really account for and but they
want to make their decision on like this
is what i believe and this is the only
way and that's kind of a problem too but
yeah
oh no
it's very touching portion in the book
uh freakonomics where they talk about um
the low crime rate
in major cities
uh there was a certain time where there
was a low crime rate that happened and
you know the whole book is about
correlation is not causation right so
they were they were saying like oh it's
because you know you know the there's
everyone's making more money now that's
why the crime is low or whatever
whatever but then what they really found
out was when abortion became legal and
people were able to do this
and because young mothers you know
they're able to pursue her higher
education they were able to like maybe
go from poverty to middle class or all
these things right they weren't having
kids at a young age and raising them
maybe making a ton of mistakes and maybe
them becoming delinquents you know and
then so
they're like it kind of sucks out of
this tragedy that's what happened but
then it did give the women the single
moms or potential single moms a fighting
chance to go out and you know
not
i guess continue the cycle because
they're probably like raised by a single
mom or something in a bad neighborhood
or whatever yeah so
um it's it's kind of hard to say because
it's like it's one of those things that
are it's so complex and and there's so
many my new details depending on where
you live depending on the culture of the
people that believe what um like if it's
a religious city like if everyone in
that city like like imagine this
happening in salt lake city it's
completely different right it's a bunch
of mormons and [ __ ] but like in la or
like whatever and then is the state
gonna take care of them and it's like
how can you answer all this crazy [ __ ]
and yeah i'm definitely not here to be
like yo am i pro-life pro-choice but i
do think i believe that like it
shouldn't be a bunch of dudes making a
decision on [ __ ] what like women have
to go through so you know especially
when they're 109 dude and it's like it's
also one thing to take into account how
much of the woman's decision is
influenced by the guy's
uh influence on her yeah luckily for me
like to end what i was sharing um
i decided we're gonna keep it and then
um i had homies at the time we all they
started like a collection pot to like
have some way to like seed some money
because i had nothing at 17.
um and then literally like
after like dealing with it for a couple
weeks
my girl like she she was oh my stomach
[ __ ] is killing me she goes to the
bathroom
miscarriage oh oh wow so it was just
over and i was like
holy [ __ ] like what a gigantic lesson to
just learn yeah you know
wow yeah i have to say that wouldn't
happen to anybody else but of course
that happens to him
and i never [ __ ] again
[Music]
you